she wasn't doing all the extra stuff but
here's where he come into play here we
go Clarkson Kessler and Sexton oh my
goodness oh and the ball goes behind the
extension
all right gotta get more than the points
they'll get more names they still hit
this that's six oh my God
actually JC is is killing him right now
there we go Colin was seven by himself
that's seven this is it yeah oh yeah
they got this though they won't see the
winner here tomorrow is set so low
Clarkson
[Applause]
well I think I called this people yep I
think I called there you did call this
one
so they got 13-13
and 200 points I'm just gonna this is a
the shooting was a little disappointing
very disappointing I mean in the NBA
today it's awesome
no yeah you're right and other than the
five-point spot these guys should have
been locked in one through four and they
were and they were yeah this is
disappointed
we can only hope the three-point
shooting contest has a little bit better
Marksmanship absolutely than this this
is
but the hometown team won so that's nice
[Music]
fans of the Jazz in our stands tonight
with all the seats filled thrilled to
have this back in Salt Lake City
well great for this fan base here
so here are the final numbers now for
the 2023 Kia skills challenge winner the
Utah Jazz and let's send it over to our
public address announcer here in
downtown Salt Lake City
America Eric Watson here to present the
2023 Kia skills challenge trophy to our
winning team the Jazz
welcome
[Music]
all right all right
we talked to you guys beforehand you
pulled out the championship right here
in front of the home crowd you're
officially a skilled challenge Champion
sir how does that feel it feels good
especially to do it in front of the home
team and uh we got a little Advantage
from the crowd we appreciate y'all for
sure Walker you hit the final winner I
just got to ask why did that look so
hard can you explain that to us
man they got a lot of nerves going on
but uh you know we knew we had to do it
for our Jazz crowd here so at the end
got the win go Jazz and I know you guys
are gonna get loud for this one Mr
Jordan Clarkson you guys the one at Utah
won it in 2008 Darren Williams 2014 Trey
Burke the third skills challenge
Champion for Utah Jazz what does that
mean
blessings
um
do it for Utah man appreciate everybody
showing love God do you know
represent love give it up for him your
Kia skills challenge champions
you two are just jealous that's the
problem oh I'm happy for him that was my
team